[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saludan juliet riaño
[Música]
la guerra deja nuevamente en medio del
conflicto a los civiles el ataque ruso
contra ucrania desencadenó una huida
masiva fuera de las fronteras del país y
el desplazamiento interno de familias
completas mientras acnur estima que la
guerra llevaría a unas 4 millones de
personas a escapar de los ataques rusos
la unión europea dice que serían hasta 7
millones veamos qué pasa en las
fronteras ucranianas
una fila de vehículos de quienes huyen
de la guerra
un camino que los lleva a cruzar las
fronteras en busca de seguridad y donde
la única certeza es alejarse de ucrania
los ataques los obligaron a empacar
algunas de sus pertenencias lo más
básico y salir es que esto sea venimos
de kiev la capital que ha sido
bombardeada donde le disparan a la gente
donde atacan lugares pacíficos y donde
disparan a nuestros hombres muy hernia
me está
es una carrera contrarreloj pero el
viaje puede incluso durar varias
jornadas luzmila va a eslovenia donde la
espera una de sus hijas
el camino fue muy duro llevamos cuatro
días de viaje con niños
spalletti durmiendo aquí en el carro
somos cinco personas el tránsito los
lleva también a hungría eslovaquia
rumanía y polonia algunos de los
primeros países receptores otros
llegaron a berlín
[Música]
la situación era muy grave en kiev y
odessa la ciudad más cercana para
nosotros
[Música]
de esa calle no tendríamos ninguna
posibilidad así que decidimos irnos con
mi familia de
familias completas buscan seguridad en
refugios improvisados y algunos esperan
que su vida sea transitoria
tenemos que sobrevivir a esta situación
peligrosa y luego queremos regresar a
nuestra patria
al menos yo quiero hacerlo si los niños
quieren vivir en otro lado pueden
quedarse pero yo con todos los años
detrás mío quiero volver a casa
el costo de los ataques es alto y la
guerra ya deja cicatrices irina y su
familia planeaban visitar a su abuela
pero al día siguiente los despertó el
sonido de los bombardeos entonces
huyeron
cuando conducíamos explotaron algunos
cohetes cerca de nosotros
así que es realmente muy peligroso los
niños en este momento tienen miedo de
los aviones y si alguien en la calle
hace algún tipo de ruido mucho ruido se
asustan
hungría que abrió sus fronteras para
recibir a los que escapan de la guerra
también acoge a personas que dejaron sus
hogares y buscaron refugio en ucrania
la situación era terrible tenía que
correr porque había explosiones aquí y
allá cada minuto
benítez valdez de boca al voluntad
samsung correr al búnker y después tomar
un tren para salir de living water vi a
este fue horrible me quedé en más de 20
horas y awards muchos de los que están
en centros de acogida en europa del
este- no son solo ucranianos hay
personas de india nigeria y de otros
países africanos refugiados que vuelven
a buscar protección
en medio de la incertidumbre por la
guerra los ucranianos se encuentran en
polonia las puertas abiertas para su
recepción nuestra corresponsal en la
frontera polaca pilar cebrián nos
reportó sobre la acogida
estamos en la extracción de trenes de 6
m que es una localidad que está a 20 km
de la frontera con ucrania y está siendo
ahora mismo el punto caliente de la
recepción de refugiados ucranianos es la
primera parada de los ucranianos que
están abandonando su país en tren y
cuando desembarcan aquí muy cansados y
muy desmoralizados se encuentran con una
terminal llena de gente como podéis ver
pero también con un verdadero centro de
acogida porque los polacos están
entregando en gestos de solidaridad y no
solamente pueden encontrar aquí agua y
comida caliente sino que también hay
mantas y una de las zonas de la terminal
se ha habilitado para que puedan pasar
aquí la noche
muchos de estos ucranianos han estado
hasta tres días esperando para cruzar la
frontera
es por eso por lo que llegan pues con
mucho frío también con mucho hambre y
por eso bueno pues de muchos polacos que
están aquí intentando ayudarles a que
entren en calor para que puedan
continuar con su camino es verdad que
algunas de las escenas más emocionantes
que se están viviendo en esta terminal
ocurren en el andén cuando llega uno de
los trenes cargados de personas de
ucrania que están huyendo de la guerra y
que al final no saben si algún día
podrán volver a su país pues hay muchos
polacos que van con pancartas con
algunos carteles escritos en ruso que ni
siquiera es en su país en su idioma
polaco y en esos carteles pone que
ofrecen una habitación de su casa que
están dispuestos a recibirles en sus
hogares durante unos días o incluso que
les pueden llevar en coche a cualquier
otra parte del país oa cualquier otra
parte de europa incluso he visto a unos
chicos de amsterdam que venían aquí a
ofrecerse para llevar a ucrania nos a
todas partes yo le preguntaba a uno de
esos polacos
que le había movido para hacer estos
estos gestos de solidaridad y decía que
tenía la sensación de que tanto europa
como la otan estaban dando la espalda
ucranianos y que los estaban dejando
solos hasta ante este terrible conflicto
también hay muchos polacos que me han
comentado aquí que quieren demostrar
quieren ayudar a los ucranianos porque
este terrible episodio les recuerda a la
segunda guerra mundial cuando ellos
dicen también fueron invadidos por un
país vecino
y sobre el éxodo desde ucrania está
europa preparada para la crisis
humanitaria que se avecina y como
responderá esta vez hasta aquí
inmigrantes de france 24 los invitamos a
comentar en nuestras redes sociales con
el hashtag migrantes f24 sigan con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]